sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder dem des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
[Musik]
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit
oder ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern
welt an
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
japan führt krieg gegen china um seinen
traum vom großen panischen reich zu
verwirklichen die sowjetunion hat
abkommen sowohl mit japan als auch mit
deutschland geschlossen
das deutsche reich hat sich weite teile
europas einverleibt polen die
tschechoslowakei
österreich luxemburg norwegen dänemark
die niederlande und belgien frankreich
wird erobert und geteilt in der einen
hälfte regiert nun ein französisches
regime mit sitz in vichy in der anderen
hälfte die deutschen im sommer 1940 will
hitler sich mit den unbeugsamen briten
befassen
[Musik]
churchill ahnt dass die luftschlacht um
england unmittelbar bevorsteht er
täuscht sich nicht europa war gefallen
und das deutsche reich stand
buchstäblich schon an der türschwelle
nur großbritannien war den deutschen bei
der eroberung europas noch im weg
doch anders als die bisherigen kämpfe
der wehrmacht wird diese schlacht nicht
am boden ausgetragen sondern am himmel
german deutschland hatte zwei ziele zum
einen die royal navy auszuschalten zum
anderen die royal airforce
beginnen musste man mit der royal
airforce die der marine bei einem
angriff ja zu hilfe eilen würde so dass
man wollte also die luftüberlegenheit
erlangen und die royal airforce
zerstören
hermann göring der oberbefehlshaber der
luftwaffe glaubt an einen schnellen sieg
er rechnet damit dass die britische jagd
abwehr in südengland binnen vier tagen
vernichtet sein wird die gesamte royal
air force will er in zwei bis vier
wochen ausschalten
[Musik]
die erste phase der luftschlacht um
england beginnt am 10 juli es ist ein
kampf um die luftüberlegenheit über
südengland
die royal airforce schickt junge
unerfahrene piloten ins gefecht über dem
ärmelkanal treffen sie auf kampferprobte
deutsche bomber geschwader
aber angst ist matthias ruhdorfer von
höhe zu ruhen doch die hohe air france
wollte von diesem plan nicht zwischen
wird ist die royal airforce bestand
nicht nur aus briten sie wurde zum
beispiel durch 30 australische piloten
unterstützt auch durch polen und
tschechien die ihren besetzten
heimatländer verlassen hatten es gab
auch fünf amerikaner und sogar ein paar
jamaikaner das war eine internationale
truppe die großbritannien verteidigen
wollte
deutschland schickte eine angriffswelle
nach der anderen
thomas die bombe wurden von
kampfflugzeugen diskutiert
ziel war es die royal airforce so
schnell wie möglich zu besiegen
zunächst griffen die deutschen die
konvois im ärmelkanal an das war die
erste phase der luftschlacht um england
gehörigen setzt drei luftflotte nein
nummer zwei und drei kommen aus
frankreich und belgien
luftflotte nummer fünf überquert die
nordsee von dänemark und norwegen aus
der deutsche pilot peter stahl ist
begeistert er sagt wohin man auch blickt
überall unsere flugzeuge
in dieser ersten phase dem kanal kampf
wollen die deutschen die
luftüberlegenheit über dem ärmelkanal
erringt doch die luftwaffe wirft nicht
nur bomben ab sie wirft auch flugblätter
über england ab sie tragen die
überschrift ein letzter appell an die
vernunft
hitler hätte lieber einen
friedensvertrag ausgehandelt aber darauf
wollte sich großbritannien nicht
einlassen
ende juli muss der frisch gekürte
reichsmarschall göring seine strategie
überdenken statt die royal airforce aus
der reserve zu locken greift er sie
direkt an in einer verschlüsselten
nachricht die der britische geheimdienst
abfängt heißt es
an alle einheiten der luft flotten 2 3
und 5 innerhalb kurzer zeit werdet ihr
die britische royal airforce vom himmel
holen heil hitler
[Musik]
unternehmen adler angriff so der code
name für die operation soll die royal
air force mit einem schlag vernichten am
13 august 1940 dem sogenannten adler tag
beginnt der angriff diroll airforce
appelliert an ihre piloten die schlacht
um england steht kurz bevor mitglieder
der royal airforce das schicksal von
generationen liegt in euren händen
august 1940 die luftschlacht um england
hat begonnen
30 kilometer über den kanal in gerade
einmal 8
[Musik]
hunderte von flugzeugen starten in vier
aufeinanderfolgenden wellen um die
englischen verteidigungslinien zu
durchbrechen
george als stabschef general hastings
mail berichtet
auf dem gartentisch stellten wir die
angriffswellen über der küste nach den
ganzen nachmittag über gab es schwere
gefechte
teilweise waren alle geschwader der
gruppe gleichzeitig im einsatz wir
hatten nichts in reserve
die
briten erkannten dass ein frontalangriff
aus nächster nähe der beste weg war um
eine messerschmitt auszuschalten
es heißt er häufig dass sie das weiße im
auge ihres gegners an aber so war es
tatsächlich
sie flogen so nah ran wie möglich und
eröffneten das feuer wirklich gefährlich
wirklich riskant aber sehr effektiv
[Musik]
am 16 august besucht winston churchill
das hauptquartier der number eleven
group in west london die einheit hatte
die hauptlast während des deutschen
angriffs getragen churchill ist tief
beeindruckt am 20 august erklärt er im
unterhaus noch nie in der geschichte
menschlicher konflikte hatten so viele
so wenigen so viel zu verdanken
[Musik]
großbritannien verfügt über bessere
radartechnik als deutschland bringt
abgeschossenen piloten schnell wieder
ins cockpit und
produziert mehr flugzeuge als sein
gegner
zudem hat es mit der spitfire und der
hurricane zwei äußerst wendige flugzeuge
die sich im luftkampf bewähren
die deutschen hoffnungen auf einen
schnellen sieg zerschlagen sich
[Musik]
am 18 august 1940 schickt winston
churchill 150 panzer nach ägypten er
geht davon aus dass sie am suezkanal
dringender gebraucht werden als in
großbritannien
die panzer umschiffen das kap der guten
hoffnung am 24 august erreichen sie vor
zeit
wo wir unsere panzer waren klein und
hatten nur ein maschinengewehr entweder
7,7 oder 12,7 millimeter damit konnte
man ein bisschen rum stänkern aber mir
auch nicht
[Musik]
am 13 september marschieren die
italiener in das von großbritannien
besetzte ägypten ein
wenn es nach mussolini geht ist dies
erst der anfang
denn als hitler 1939 die
tschechoslowakei besetzt hatte mussolini
sich beschwert
die italiener lachen mich aus
jedes mal wenn hitler ein land erobert
schickt er mir einen groß
am 28 oktober setzt mussolini noch einen
drauf den verärgerten hitler lässt er
wissen führer wir sind auf dem vormarsch
die siegreichen italienischen truppen
haben im morgengrauen die griechisch
albanische grenze überquert
italien hatte griechenland zuvor ein
ultimatum gestellt doch die antwort der
helenen war unmissverständlich
nein
italien italienischen divisionen bern
mickrig er nannte sie die visionen wahr
dass noch mehr klang aber tatsächlich
waren es nur ein paar regimenter
mitte november bläst die griechische
armee zum gegenangriff die deutschen
kommandeure beraten ihre strategie für
den mittelmeerraum
hitlers adjutant gerhard engel sagt über
hitler
im moment weiß er nicht was er tun soll
ostbevern mussolini anfang seiner art
mentor für hitler war führte etwa sich
ihm auf seltsame fast schon
freundschaftliche art verpflichtet
[Musik]
am 14 november 1940 starten die griechen
einen gegenangriff rossellinis truppen
geraten in die defensive hitler muss dem
dusche zu hilfe eilen
griechenland feldzug ist ein perfektes
beispiel dafür was alles schief gehen
kann wenn ein diktator nicht auf seine
militärs hört
währenddessen sind die briten auf dem
besten wege die luftschlacht um england
für sich zu entscheiden
ein model angie
ein ball an die menschen
[Musik]
zwischen dem 24 august und dem 3
september verliert die luftwaffe bei
ihren angriffen 380 maschinen
auf seiten der briten sind es 286
[Musik]
hitler ändert seine strategie
am 17 september zeigt ein britisches
radar den anflug hunderter flugzeuge
375 deutsche flugzeuge dollar an die
themse hinauf die luftschlacht um
england wird zur schlacht um london
die royal airforce schickt elf staffeln
in die luft sie sollen angriffe auf
flugplätze und andere infrastruktur
abwehren
die chance standen sechs acht oder zehn
zu eins trotzdem stoßen sie sich um die
schlacht und riefen den alten nachkommen
300 deutsche bomber sowie 600 begleit
jäger nehmen kurs auf london
der sogenannte blitz erreicht die
hauptstadt
der flieger alarm ertönte gegen 11 uhr
wir standen auf und gingen auf die
straße als wir hochkochten sahen wir wie
leuchtbomben über der stadt abgeworfen
wurden
und da sagte mein vater dass wir das
ziel waren und so war es auch
sie wenden werden gezielt über england
abgewaschen über geschäften und mühlen
häusern und bauernhöfen
überall in rom blieben die menschen in
dieser nacht ziehen die diese sie sind
die leidtragenden der nazi barbarei
die ersten bomben treffen die londoner
dogs die augenzeugin joe west beschreibt
das grauen des angriffs
wenn ich sage dass der himmel schwarz
weiß dass keine übertreibung er war
schwarz von großen bombern und
dazwischen flogen die spitfires
[Musik]
acht wochen lang fliegen juden 8 200
deutsche bomber über london und
herrschen ihre tödliche fracht ab
[Musik]
der nachthimmel über london ist hell
erleuchtet
die karts zwischen september und
november 1904 schlägt der zweite brand
von london genannt in einer nach jedem
1500 drängte durch deutsche bomber nennt
die bomben fallen unter anderem auf
london south hampton bristol cardiff
liverpool und manchester
tägliche effizienz überwiegend maschen
deutsche bomber die stadt
durchschnittlich 30.000 schuss aus der
flachs sind nötig um ein deutsches
flugzeug vom himmel zu holen
doch angesichts eines stück preises von
gerade einmal fünf pfund pro granate sei
das gut angelegtes geld so der
schriftsteller george orwell
[Musik]
die psychologie bei merzig lautete
bestimmen jugend statt das rückgrat und
england führte anbetteln macht zu
übernehmen und damit die angriffe
ausführen rund um die uhr über ziehen
deutsche flugzeuge london hektar neuer
hitler hofft dass die bombenangriffe
großbritannien in die knie zwingen
werden ganz ohne den einmarsch von
bodentruppen
doch er irrt mit bomben allein lässt
sich die moral der briten nicht brechen
es wurden so viele zivilisten getötet
und so viel zerstörung angerichtet
doch all das hat die menschen nur noch
fester zusammen geschweißt
die zivilbevölkerung wollte mit
einbezogen werden sie wollte gebraucht
werden
die bevölkerung war teil des kampfes und
sie war bereit die damit einhergehenden
widrigkeiten in kauf zu nehmen
eric luftangriffe und massiven
bombardements sollten die
zivilbevölkerung zermürben und
demoralisieren
aber das passiert nicht die briten
verloren weder ihre fassung noch ihren
humor
gemeinde briten waren überzeugt dass sie
nicht verlieren würden
mit ihre unversehrtheit triumphierte sie
über das böse und zwangen hitler in die
knie
im oktober verliert die luftwaffe 3 179
flugzeuge die royal airforce
zu staffeln damit können die nazis
deutsche verlust gemacht verkauften ein
deutscher pilot beschreibt die rückkehr
zum stützpunkt als flug über ein meer
aus fallschirmen und piloten in
rettungswesten und öllachen
[Musik]
bereits mitte september ist klar dass
der erhoffte schnelle sieg über england
wunschdenken ist
hätten die deutschen an der taktik
festgehalten die rolle airforce
auszuschalten um anschließend eine
invasion zu starten hätten sie
vielleicht eine chance gehabt doch die
entscheidung london zu bombardieren war
ein schwerer fehler das war kein
präzisionsbomben und das ziel die
bevölkerung zu zermürben wurde verfehlt
[Musik]
noch bis mai 1941 gehen die angriffe der
deutschen weiter doch die luftschlacht
um england haben sie verloren
aber kein einziger deutscher soldat hat
politischen würden getreten
während der luftschlacht um england
verliert die deutsche luftwaffe mehr als
1700 91 flugzeuge auf seiten der briten
sind es 1250
als churchill die zerstörten stadtteile
londons besucht kommen ihm die tränen
[Musik]
die hände
auf der jagd flugzeugflotte und die
fähigkeiten der wohl erst die nazi
angreifer in der luft zurückzuschlagen
ebenso wichtig für das stupa flotte der
wohl eher forsch
großbritannien und das kann man wolf
sind auf sich allein gestellt wenn
erweise alle europäischen verbündeten
waren besiegt großbritannien buhlt um
die unterstützung der usa und will diese
zum kriegseintritt bewegen doch dafür
musste man sich als kampfbereite
verbündeter erweisen und den krieg an
die deutschen herantragen
[Musik]
bereits ende august hatte die royal
airforce begonnen deutsche städte
anzugreifen
[Musik]
die häufig die wolfsburger angriffe von
rekordverdächtiger intensität die tat
angriffe in den besetzten gebieten
machen ihn dort schon mehr und mehr zu
schaffen
macht wird die mensa schaden angerichtet
und wir haben das wort vom staat georgia
dass die offensive noch verstärkt wird
dieses massiven bombardements aus der
luft war eine neue form der
kriegsführung der ökonomischen
kriegsführung
dadurch die zerstörung von fabriken
rüstungsbetrieben und ölraffinerien
wurde die deutsche kampffähigkeit enorm
geschwächt
fabrik
lagerhäuser straßen und stützpunkte
werften
boxclub ledger für ihn
eine gruppe wie die briten zerstörten
die fabriken und auch die umliegende
infrastruktur um sicher zu gehen dass
die schäden nicht so schnell wieder
repariert werden können
[Musik]
wie das chaos das in der stadt dort und
nach stift
[Musik]
dies ist weil das ist ein seltsamer
widerspruch großbritannien hat er den
blitz erlitten und wurde durch ihn sogar
im widerstand geeint trotzdem glaubte
man zwei jahre später das eine noch
heftigere bombardierungen die moral der
deutschen brechen würde doch das
entbehrt jeder grundlage
bei deutschen luftangriffen auf rund ein
dutzend britische städte werden im lauf
des krieges rund 60.000 zivilisten
getötet die zahl der deutschen
todesopfer durch alliierte
bombenangriffe wird auf 400.000 bis
600.000 geschätzt
da wo es weh tut was ihm ein
in italien starben etwa 60.000
zivilisten durch luftangriffe
schon einen tag nach dem kriegseintritt
italiens im juni 1940 empfehlen die
ersten bomben auf das land
[Musik]
turin und mailand wurden bombardiert es
fehlen so viele bomben dass etliche in
schutzräumen zuflucht suchten oder aufs
land flüchteten
jetzt spricht die zeit nach zu lassen im
gegenteil jetzt geht es alle kräfte für
einen möglichen and sport zu sammeln
rund 500.000 sowjetische zivilisten
werden bei luftangriffen getötet
300.000 chinesen sterben durch
japanische bomben und auch 500.000
japaner werden im bombenhagel getötet
[Musik]
die briten hatten eine etwas
eigenwillige sicht auf die
zivilbevölkerung anderer staaten sie
glaubten dass bombenterror die menschen
beugen würde aber tatsächlich wurden sie
noch entschlossener
sie wollten kämpfen und gewinnen das
haben die briten bei ihren luftangriffen
unterschätzt
[Musik]
anders als die achsenmächte bedienten
sich die alliierten nicht der
ideologischen rechtfertigung dass eine
friedliche koexistenz von staaten nur
dann möglich wäre wenn weite teile der
zivilbevölkerung aus gelöscht würden
anders hitler er propagiert die
überlegenheit der germanischen und der
arischen rasse
und für die will er neue
siedlungsgebiete im osten erobern im
nazi jargon lebensraum
artikel zog es nicht nach besten sondern
immer schon nach osten dort wollte er
die risiken agrarflächen der zu einer
meinung nach minderwertigen slawischen
völker in besitz nehmen
der begriff rasse ist gerade im hinblick
auf das judentum und stritten und hat
sich im laufe der zeit verändert in der
geschichte des judentums ging es
eigentlich nie um diese frage
die nazis sind besessen von der
rassenfrage und konstruieren einen juden
probleme bei der planung für ein ost
ministerium fällt schon ende märz 1941
das wort endlösung am 31 juli
unterzeichnet reichsmarschall göring
eine weisung an gestapo chef reinhard
heydrich es geht im nazi jargon um die
gesamt lösung der judenfrage für
millionen von juden wird es das
todesurteil sein
[Musik]
zu diesem zeitpunkt sind die polnischen
juden bereits in ghettos eingepfercht
[Musik]
die ghettos waren unfassbar schrecklich
je länger der krieg dauerte desto
unerträglicher wurden sie hängen wo es
muss
30.000 menschen männer frauen kinder
säuglinge schwangere kranke alle ein
ganzes volk wir mussten in die ärmsten
stadtviertel ziehen in kleinen hütten
warschauer ghetto lebt und eine halbe
million menschen auf einer fläche von
drei quadratkilometern
auf jedes verfügbare zimmer kamen etwa
sieben menschen
[Musik]
es gab keinen großen unterschied
zwischen konzentrationslagern und
ghettos
[Musik]
die häftlinge mussten zwangsarbeit
leisten falls labour sie lebten unter
menschenunwürdigen bedingungen und
wurden kaum medizinisch versorgt einige
verhungerten
[Musik]
menschen bekamen etwa 400 kalorien pro
person und tag
später waren es dann nur noch 200
kalorien
überflüssig zu erwähnen dass das viel zu
wenig war um zu überleben
wegen der schlechten hygiene brothers
aus wir waren doppelt gebeutelt
very much das war durchaus beabsichtigt
die deutschen besatzer wollten das so
zum einen weil sie keinen respekt vor
osteuropäer hatten und zum anderen weil
lebensmittel in erster linie den
deutschen vorbehalten waren
waren eine art zwischenlösung
die juden wurden in den ghettos
weggesperrt eingekerkert und isoliert um
jeglichen kontakt zwischen juden und
nichtjuden zu zerstören
[Musik]
sobald ihre arbeitskraft nicht mehr
vonnöten war wurden sie vernichtet
mit anderen worten die menschen im
ghetto lippen nur auf abruf
[Musik]
im jahr 1940 bestimmen bombenterror und
mordkommandos das leben in europa doch
auch andernorts wird gekämpft etwa in
china oder
afrika
[Musik]
während bomben auf london regnen
besetzen italienische truppen im august
1940 kritisch somaliland
um druck auf die italiener auszuüben
marschiert eine alliierte truppen unter
general plattform sudan aus in
italienisch ostafrika ein die truppen
von general sir allen cunningham rücken
aus kenia 1 nach mitchells
kriegserklärung waren die britischen
staat kräftigen gruppen mehr als bereit
nach monaten des wartens franken wieder
darauf wirklich die kranken zu erreichen
und im youtube zu ziehen
auch der südafrikaner cliff everton
kämpft auf seiten der briten wir legten
hunderte von kilometern zurück das
meiste davon zu fuß
[Musik]
wir hatten zwar truppentransporter aber
dieser teil afrikas war wüste die hälfte
der zeit zogen wir unsere lastwagen aus
dem sand
unser erster kampfeinsatz stand bevor
wir waren neue rekruten und hatten keine
ahnung was uns erwartete genau wie die
offiziere
die truppen die nach italienisch
ostafrika vordringen stoßen auf
erbitterten widerstand und widrigsten
bedingungen
general platz beschreibt den kampf um
die stadt kehre ein äußerst zäher kampf
ein echter soldaten krieg der feind war
uns zahlenmäßig klar überlegen hatte das
tor selbst gewählt und konnte unsere
truppenbewegungen daher genau
nachvollziehen
[Musik]
indische truppen nehmen schließlich das
zerklüftete kampfgebiet 1
obwohl die italiener aus allen rohren
feuern sind sie unterlägen
general wafer sagt später zu churchill
diese nuss war hart zu knappen
cunninghams truppe macht 50.000
gefangenen und erobert mehr als 900
30.000 quadratkilometer fläche
verluste 500 männer und vier gefangenen
mit unbezahlbaren trieben sie die
italiener mit meter aus ihrer
vermeintlichen waren stellung die
verluste sind aber die zahl der
gefangenen ist immens
ein britischer veteran sagt später
diejenigen die an anderen fronten
gekämpft haben wissen dass nichts
schlimmer war als kehren
general plett erklärt seinen männern
dass diejenigen die schlacht gewinnen
die am längsten durchhalten ich weiß ihr
haltet länger durch als die anderen und
ich verspreche euch ich halte länger
durch als mein gegenüber
platz männer haben eine schlacht
gewonnen doch der krieg ist noch lange
nicht vorüber alle soldaten des
ostafrika feldzugs wurden auf truppen
schiffe verladen wir fuhren das rote
meer hinauf bis nach ägypten
viele werden in nordafrika eingesetzt
und später auch bei der invasion der
westalliierten in italien sie werden
erst zur ruhe kommen wenn dieser krieg
beendet ist doch zunächst tobt er weiter
in großbritannien kontinentaleuropa
afrika und asien
[Musik]
im april 1940 beugt sich winston
churchill dem druck der japaner er
sperrt die burma straße und hofft
dadurch einen friedensschluss zwischen
china und japan zu erreichen
die bochumer straße war wichtig um die
45 chinesischen divisionen im kampf
gegen die japaner mit nachschub zu
versorgen und sie so im krieg zu halten
der nachschub wurde über den himalaya
eingeflogen
doch es kommt zu einem friedensschluss
im gegenteil japan mit seinen neuen
kriegsminister general toki weitet seine
offensive aus es kündigt an seinen
machtbereich durch eine große
ostasiatische wohlstands fähre weiter
auszubauen
[Musik]
japan war ein militarist isches regime
das heißt die admiräle und generäle
bestimmten alle aspekte der japanischen
regierung sowohl innen als auch
außenpolitisch sie dirigierten das
schicksal des gesamten landes
der junge soldat qureshi hat sich
freiwillig gemeldet um für seinen kaiser
zu kämpfen
japan muss den kontinent entwickeln und
china in der mandschurei kontrollieren
zumindest hatte mein vater das immer
gesagt
in meinem dorf galt ich als
patriotisches kind ich wollte in den
krieg gegen china ziehen
kaiser hirohito erklärt
premierminister koné ist der ansicht
dass das china problem nicht gleich zu
lösen sein wird und befürwortet einen
vorstoß nach süden am 27 september 1940
unterzeichnet japan den drei mächte pakt
mit italien und deutschland
hj
der vorsitzende des geheimen rat ahnt
was dieser schritt für sein land
bedeutet der drei mächte pakt ist ein
bündnis auch gegen die vereinigten
staaten
[Musik]
ich gehe davon aus dass die usa
ökonomischen druck auf japan ausüben
werden wahrscheinlich verbieten sie den
export von öl und eisen
die achsenmächte kontrollieren nur einen
bruchteil der weltweiten ölproduktion
und der raffinerien
stalin wird später sagen der krieg sei
durch motoren und oktan entschieden
worden
die deutschen truppen sichern sich in
rumänien den zugang zu den ölanlagen in
place
fortan kommen von dort 60 prozent der
deutschen ölimporte
[Musik]
am tag nach der einnahme der ölfelder
sagt präsident roosevelt
vielleicht werden deutsche und japaner
eines tages irgendeine dummheit begehen
und uns dadurch mit hineinziehen das ist
die einzige wirkliche gefahr in die wir
geraten können
churchill öffnet die burma straße so
dass china wieder nachschub beziehen
kann zudem gewährt england der republik
china einen zehn millionen pfund kredit
ist salz kommunisten und nationalisten
sich darauf einigten gemeinsam gegen die
japaner vorzugehen änderte sich auch die
chinesische politik sie wurde nicht
demokratisch im liberalen sinn aber es
gab mehr pluralismus mehr möglichkeiten
für die menschen über neue ideen und
über eine nachkriegsgesellschaft zu
diskutieren
[Musik]
wien 20 november 1940 in anwesenheit
hitlers schließt sich ungarn den
achsenmächten an
drei tage später folgt rumänien einen
weiteren tag später die slowakei
am 18 dezember lässt hitler weisung
nummer 21
die deutsche wehrmacht muss darauf
vorbereitet sein auch vor beendigung des
krieges gegen england sowjetrussland in
einem schnellen feldzug niederzuwerfen
[Musik]
die deutschen planten zwar einen angriff
auf die sowjetunion hatten aber immer
noch die briten im hinterkopf das kalkül
war wenn wir die sowjets ausschalten
werden die briten erkennen dass sie
keine verbündeten mehr haben nicht mal
einen potenziellen verbündeten wie die
sowjetunion dann werden sie vernunft
annehmen und friedensverhandlungen
eingehen das war sehr strategisch
gedacht
ende januar 1941 das japanische
finanzministerium
genehmigt das drucken von invasions geld
für die geplante einnahme der
philippinen britisch malagas und
niederländisch ostindien
zeitgleich kommt es zu rationierungen
zudem teilt der japanische botschafter
dem vichy-regime mit das japanische
truppen in französisch indochina
einmarschieren werden und dass die
flugzeuge nahe britisch malaria und
niederländisch ostindien stationieren
werden
der us außenminister drängt große welt
zu neuen sanktionen
doch seine militärs raten ab sie sagen
das würde wahrscheinlich sehr bald zu
einem angriff japans auf malaria und
niederländisch ostindien führen und
könnte die usa vorzeitig in einen
pazifik krieg verwickeln
dennoch verhängte amerika sanktionen
[Musik]
an photoshop damit trat ein was japan
immer befürchtet hatte
doch fakt nämlich dass plötzlich eine
machbar ist die dem land in öl hand zu
drehen kann um design capital einfrieren
und seine exporte ab werden kann
das gefühl der unsicherheit das in japan
der zwischen kriegsjahre vorherrschte
war jetzt zu einer realität
[Musik]
schauplatz eines dramas das in der
geschichte der diplomatie seines
gleichen sucht
im august 1941 treffen sich churchill
und roosevelt auf dem britischen
kriegsschiff prince of wales es herrscht
höchste geheimhaltung sie wollen eine
gemeinsame marschroute für den weiteren
kriegsverlauf und eine mögliche
nachkriegsordnung festlegen
als churchill franklin roosevelt traf
war das für ihn wie eine begegnung mit
dem herrgott höchstpersönlich
denn für ihn war rose welt der einzige
der großbritannien wirklich retten
konnte
die beiden länder wussten nicht viel
übereinander es gab ja weder fernsehen
noch internet ein us-präsident und ein
britischer premierminister haben
möglicherweise weniger gemeinsamkeiten
als man denkt kommen
[Musik]
die beeindruckendste schiene die sich an
deck der fünf fouls abspielte war der
gottesdienst alle anwesenden von premier
über den präsidenten bis nur zum
einfachen seemann erklärten wird gottes
hilfe die freiheit auf der ganzen welt
verteidigen zu wollen
die beiden staatschefs geben eine
erklärung ab die als atlantik charta in
die geschichte eingeht darin halten sie
fest dass es in diesem kampf nicht um
territorium und macht geht sondern um
rechte und prinzipien
große teile dieser erklärung werden
wenige monate später als grundlage für
die deklaration der vereinten nationen
dienen doch als churchill stellvertreter
clement attlee das ergebnis des treffens
im radio verkündet sind viele briten
enttäuscht denn aus seinen worten wird
klar dass die vereinigten staaten nicht
in den krieg eintreten wollen
[Musik]
vier monate später wird die prince of
wales vor der küste britisch malaria es
von japanischen flugzeugen versenkt
zusammen mit harry pauls
winston churchill ist schockiert
die briten haben zwei ihrer besten
schiffe verloren
zu beginn des jahres 1941 waren
britische truppen aus ägypten in
griechenland eingetroffen
[Musik]
nachdem italien griechenland angegriffen
hatte griffen die briten ihrerseits in
griechenland ein damit bedrohten sie
aber deutschlands interessen in
südeuropa deutschland musste auf die
britische bedrohung reagieren
[Musik]
überstunden gries während der kämpfe in
griechenland wurden die meisten unserer
panzer zerstört weil wir keine
ersatzteile hatten das war nördlich von
themen als die flugzeuge kamen suchten
wir zuflucht in einem graben und dann
platzte eine andere art von bombe denn
es hieß plötzlich jeder kämpft für sich
allein die griechische regierung war
zusammengebrochen das war's dann
[Musik]
am 6 april 1941 einen monat nach dem
eintreffen der briten in griechenland
überfällt deutschland jugoslawien am 17
april kapitulieren die jugoslawischen
streitkräfte
eine woche später am 27
april ergeben sich auch die griechen
[Musik]
ihr mut hier durchhaltewille und ihr
notorischer geist der unbesiegbarkeit
ihre liebe und ihre opfer werden nicht
umsonst gewesen sein
[Musik]
die britischen truppen werden nach kreta
evakuiert doch george code knacker
warnen vor einer bevorstehenden
deutschen invasion
[Musik]
wenig später springen 15.000 deutsche
fallschirmjäger über kreta ab schätzen
jedoch die truppenstärke des gegners
falsch ein
die deutschen fallschirmjäger sprangen
aus geringer höhe ab sie waren starken
beschuss durch handfeuerwaffen
ausgesetzt und erlitten hohe verluste
[Musik]
dennoch gelingt es deutschen und
italienischen truppen kreta einzunehmen
diese bilder sprechen bände
die deutsche luftwaffe vom auto
griechenland fast nach belieben
wir haben nicht genug zeugung sie
zurückzuschlagen der langstreckenflieger
war über flugzeuge und maschinen aller
art werden jetzt benötigt
[Musik]
am 27 mai beschließt das britische
oberkommando kreta zu räumen
die schlacht ist verloren
staff sergeant raymond reihen erinnert
sich
als ich aufwachte wehten überall weiße
fahnen man sagte mir das hauptquartier
sei in der nacht aufgegeben worden und
man habe den befehl zur kapitulation
gegeben
die britischen truppen sollen um jeden
preis evakuiert werden
andrew cunningham sagt
wenn sie meine herren der armee auf
kreta die kapitulation befehlen wird
unsere flotte dennoch die royals retten
[Musik]
die deutschen hatten kreta mit seinen
flugplätzen erobert und konnten jetzt
ihre sie und luft macht im mittelmeer
weiter ausbauen
eine woche nach der evakuierung
marschieren britische und französische
truppen in syrien und im libanon ein
james corden ist mitglied des 31
australischen bataillons als sie ihm das
victoria kreuz verliehen wird heißt es
er kroch durch einen hagel von
maschinengewehr und granatfeuer und
tötete 4 mg schützen mit dem bajonett
am 10 mai 1941 fliegt hitlers
stellvertreter rudolf heß ohne hitlers
wissen nach schottland
als ihm der treibstoff ausgeht springt
er mit dem fallschirm ab verletzt sich
am knöchel und kommt in gewahrsam
[Musik]
hitler schon vor wut
es wollte vor dem geplanten
russlandfeldzug einen separatfrieden mit
den briten aushandeln doch dazu wird es
nicht mehr kommen denn hitler schafft
tatsachen er sagt seinen generellen der
bevorstehende kampf ist ein kampf zweier
weltanschauungen die jüdisch
bolschewistische intelligenz muss
beseitigt werden
es ist der startschuss für unternehmen
barbarossa der vernichtungsfeldzug gegen
die sowjetunion
am 22 juni 1941 dem 129 jahrestag von
napoleons einmarsch in russland
überfallen drei millionen deutsche
soldaten und über 600.000 truppen aus
finnland italien rumänien ungarn und der
slowakei
die sowjetunion
sie stürmen auf leningrad kiew und
smolensk zu
britische experten geben der roten armee
zehn tage us-experten zwischen einem und
drei monaten
doch es sollte anders kommen